[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut les gars vous m'aviez demandé
toutes les adresses vous faire épiler
l'éboulis chaud et c'est vrai les mercis
sa distance à des gages à et ferme la
porte derrière toi à nos dérives c'est
moi c'est ton frère
ouais qu'est ce que tu veux être et
voilà je viens de recevoir ton nouveau
canapé et je crois que je me suis
légèrement planté commencé à planter
qu'est ce que tu as pas encore comme
conneries écoute le mieux c'est que tu
viens me voir il faut soit bien chars
peu plus et l h au mas de la famille je
veux faire défoncer oui bonjour monsieur
il est interdit de stationner csa a
continué eux et tu as mené cette gare
est là parce que ça jouait regarde c'est
ma carte monoprix le si tu me laisses
pages met la faute dans le cul pardon
monsieur d'eric je ne vous avais pas
reconnu et quand c'est pas grave
la prochaine fois ta gueule champagne
couscous à couvrir et monsieur d'eric je
vous adore de tpm peut aussi voir nature
au rayon des hélices en plein là non
c'est un vrai connard oh la la qu'est-ce
qui les sens passe d'éric je laisse mon
numéro des fois qu'ils cherchent un plan
cul lui c'est pas possible mais c'est
quoi ce canapé de merde tu te fout de la
gueule de qui est dit je sais pas j'ai
essayé les imprimés je me suis dit que
ça mettrait un peu de fantaisie chez toi
mais sans déconner métier vraiment la
chaume a de la famille c'est le vendeur
il m'avait dit que c'était joli donc
j'ai qu'est-ce que j'en fais de ce
canapé de merde je t'avais dit que je
voulais à château d'ax château d'ax
non mais ça va tu sais c'est pas c'est
pas si mal allez je te jure arrête de
parler hendrick je vais pisser dessus
sur ma vie j'ai pissé dessus maintenant
j'ai plus qu'à me démerder pour m'en
débarrasser
et elle monte mon ami et mon frère
écoutez franchement tu y est la première
personne que j'appelle j'ai un coup à
faire sur un canapé en d'imprimer c'est
la dernière tendance
une vraie merveille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]